bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors selon michel barnier
le négociateur en chef de l'union
européenne le royaume uni se refuse de
s'engager sérieusement est-ce réellement
le cas où il vous prendre en compte
quand même une réalité c'est que cette
épidémie de coronavirus arrive au pire
moment des négociations à un moment où
on avait besoin d'une forte
disponibilité et cette disponibilité
départ vraiment là je vous rappelle que
les deux négociateurs david frost et
michel barnier ont tous les deux étaient
touchés par le virus du gros navires us
mais aussi d'alliés de thomson qui lui
le premier ministre qui lui est toujours
en convalescence à veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'au niveau dote d'un holding
street
on n'ose pas ou ne veut pas pour
l'instant s'engager plus loin dans les
négociations
considérant que si on le fait on se
découvre un peu trop et donc il ya une
tentation très forte de la part des
britanniques de se dire finalement on va
attendre et on va profiter du fait que
peut-être les vingt-sept sont dans une
situation d'un certain désarroi
on l'a vu notamment lorsqu'il s'agit de
trouver des méthodes pour mutualiser
éventuellement une dette qui pourrait
être la conséquence de cette crise du
cradat virus en europe dont condé face à
deux positions de principe qui pour
l'instant n'évolue pas c'est assez
préoccupant parce qu'il ne reste que
deux sessions de négociations d'ici le
30 juin et le 30 juin c'est la date à
laquelle normalement la date limite à
laquelle les britanniques devront dire
s'ils veulent prolonger ou pas ces
négociations or ils ont très clairement
fait savoir qu'il ne voulait pas
prolonger ces négociations donc on d une
partie de bras de fer extrêmement
difficile sur un point en particulier
sur le fait que les européens veulent
absolument conserver la cohérence d'un
accord d'ensemble un accord d'ensemble
qui se tient par tous ses aspects or les
britanniques très clairement veulent des
accords un petit peu séparés pour
essayer d'affaiblir la position
européenne et pouvoir profiter
finalement de chaque possibilité sans
les vrais par exemple pour la pêche la
pêche c'est un domaine sur lequel les
européens considèrent qu'il faut un
accord a priori nécessaire
les britanniques se disent cet accord
ils pourraient être séparées on le fait
on le fera plus loin pour d'autres
domaines la réglementation les
britanniques veulent conserver leur
liberté de manoeuvre en matière fiscale
en matière réglementaire
or pour les européens il n'est pas
question de se passer d'un accord global
qui est la seule condition pour lequel
les britanniques pourraient conserver un
accès au marché unique qui je le
rappelle est une condition nécessaire
pour éviter un véritable arbre excite
alors la date butoir de juin pour
évaluer les chances d'un accord se
rapproche à grands pas on sait que
londres continue jusqu'à aujourd'hui a
refusé de réclamer une prolongation de
la période de transition alors comment
pourrait-on échappé à nos deals avant la
fin de l'année on a encore le temps
d'ici la fin de l'année et d'ici le 30
juin je vous rappelle que lorsqu'il
s'est agi de négation négocié l'accord
de sortie
les britanniques avaient aussi pris des
positions extrêmement dur extrêmement
rigoureuse et quand vous de négociation
finalement ils se sont un peu assouplie
donc c'est un peu le cas de toute
négociation
lorsque la négociation commence à monter
effectivement les positions se
durcissent
jusqu'au moment où il faut bien que
quelqu'un ou les deux de préférence
s'essaye d'assouplir leur position et
donc cesser de salon il s'agit mais
encore une fois je le répète si les
britanniques veulent rentrer dans cette
négociation en pouvoir bénéficier du
beurre et de l'argent du beurre c'est à
dire accès au marché unique tout en
conservant sa totale liberté de madère
notamment sur le plan réglementaire et
bien ça c'est parfaitement inacceptable
pour les 27 qui évite de le faire savoir
d'ailleurs très bien merci beaucoup
françois paul et mathis d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes journaliste et spécialiste des
institutions européennes